gotcha how warm airship infinitive
Cynthia woman guide our tour
he's teaching the challenge continuity
run woman like uncanny Mandir churchy
tie Lila Shan Mei young thi yes we have
attached racket to a stick so this is
one of the world's longest table tennis
rackets ever probably but let's see we
can play with it oh that's a really good
spin actually
[Music]
ah
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice one
[Applause]
[Music]
finding the rhythm exactly
[Music]
next is an Instagram challenge from
Johnny wins he wants us to play with the
table I think it's the biggest racket
I've ever had
[Music]
[Music]
Jesus how you play table tennis with the
table
[Music]
should I quit that one also but no can
do
so last time we sliced an apple and this
time we'll try a banana now this is not
gonna work
you know not gonna happen
[Applause]
[Music]
come on yes I did it was a perfect hit
look at that straight in the middle ever
mammoths subscribe to our channel here
and watch our previously here they're my
rights not